hey guys I wanted to do a video for
those people who can't do Keto and
intermittent fasting a hundred percent okay
they can sort of do it but they're
having a hard time staying consistent
okay well here's the thing if something
is better than nothing okay so do what
you can work towards the ideal scene
okay but there's relative importance
--is you have things that are moderately
bad and you have things that are really
really bad to avoid and I want to just
kind of make the distinction between the
two in this list
these are the things you really want to
stay away from okay if you cheat or go
off the program and that would be soda
because it's just pure sugar and juice
pure sugar especially if the juice in
the soda is made with high fructose corn
syrup so that's really really really bad
to cheat with or to go off the program
with candy which is usually made from
high-fructose corn syrup or or our
dextrose they never use you know actual
cane sugar anymore but still candy wood
is concentrated sugar a doughnut which
is completely refined carbohydrate and
fat and sugar on top of that you want to
avoid that diet soda so not good
long-term so if you're a chronic diet
soda drinker it could create a lot of
health problems down the road not right
away but down the road so I would
recommend to avoid this one canned fruit
with syrup I've heard is corn syrup
really bad
okay so avoid that like the plague and
then also the combination of meat with
sugar okay so if you were to go to a
Chinese restaurant or a fast food
restaurant and they serve this sweet
sauce around the meat really bad
barbecue sauce
really bad the combination is really bad
because it it increases something that
makes your blood really really sticky
and it's real thick and it can create
problems with your heart okay and even
plaquing meatloaf is the combination of
their bread with meat if you have a
hamburger with ketchup which is high
fructose corn syrup with the bun
really bad then when you add starch to
that
on top of that with this meal so you're
doing some greasy fries okay so that's
not good this combination is not going
to be good for your insulin levels at
all so then you have the combination of
fat and sugar like an ice cream
traditional ice cream you have all this
high fat with a ton of sugar not a good
combination so any combination with
protein or sugar or fat and sugar is not
good all right now the occasional list
right here let's say you do a sweet
potato a yam just potato rice okay so
have it occasionally it's definitely
better than these things right here okay
alcohol make sure if you're doing
alcohol occasionally small amounts
you're doing something more dry and not
so sweet fruit well it's definitely
better than these if you have some
occasional fruit or beans or unsweetened
yogurt these are things that I would
kind of if you're going to cheat that do
these right here and not these right
here let's say you go off track and you
want to repair the damage there's a
couple things I'm gonna recommend
electrolyte powder this puts the
potassium back in you'll feel better
quick if you do it you can take a drink
of it and you'll feel a lot better
and then the wheatgrass juice powder
this is like putting the nutrients back
in simply because a lot of these foods
deplete vitamins and minerals so we want
to put them back in and have you get
right back on track now if there's a
holiday a birthday party a social event
go off the program get right back on the
program the way that I would recommend
looking at this is if you were to just
take a sheet of paper and divide it down
the center and just look at it from the
standpoint of in a given day how many
things do you do to create your health
okay are you exercising
are you sleeping good are you doing
things to lower your stress are you
eating healthy and then all the things
are you doing to counter create your
health okay you know whatever that is
and you want to make sure you keep
creating your health every single day
that's how you get healthy thanks for
watching
hey guys so I'm doing a survey of a
future video and I wanted to find out
what your biggest body problem is so
that way the content is aligning with
something that you are personally
interested in so please click the link
down below fill it out and I will create
the video thanks